customers
it seems you really like mental
entrances and I'm someone who gives you
what you want so here we go here are
more legendary Mentor entrances in anime
starting out this second volume of the
mentors list we have Gillian coming to
save rudius
yeah a moment from one of the arcs I
like from early mushoku tensei this
scene happens towards the end of rudius
and eris's Escape prior to this they
found themselves in quite a pickle after
Rudy's plan goes horribly wrong
thankfully they're not alone in this
fight though I just love how Dynamic the
anime team made the entry here it
probably has to do with how the scenes
presented from guillaine's perspective
for much of the rescue when she drops
down to break the sword in a series of
freeze frames you really get to
experience the moment it does a great
job of selling to ask Elaine's power and
the preceding demolition of the
criminals as just the icing on the cake
it is a short moment but you can easily
tell that much care has been put into it
much like mushoku 10 says anime
adaptation in a nutshell
saitama's entrance in the meteor seat is
another moment I'd like us to appreciate
the punch man is about one overpowered
hero who easily sweeps away the
competition now it doesn't sound too
engaging for someone new and hasn't
watched the anime itself I can
understand that but can we give some
props to the anime team for giving us so
many Goosebumps inducing and tearful
moments before the titular hero comes to
save the day the anime team sure knows
how to present the hype and tension in
such a good way and this scene featuring
the meteor is no different genos gets
his time to shine and he's sure made
trying to stop the meteor a spectacle
even if we all know it's just an
appetizer for the main event it only
makes the moment more awesome after
janos's fight Scythe armor comes and we
get to see him showcase once again while
he's one of the most overpowered
characters in anime the way he destroyed
the meteor in such an over-the-top
manner is great and the hive genocide
beforehand only serve to help us prepare
ourselves for the awesomeness that was
about to follow
[Music]
up next we have the black ball saving
our star from execution
Arthur's done some crazy entrances
himself the most notable one being the
scene with finrath but what about the
time when he's the one who needs saving
instead count on the awesome Yami and
the rest of the black balls to save the
day this time round what really sells
this scene is how the black balls crash
the party appearing not completely in
view of the camera at first in a scene
that allows us to let it all sink in
driving up the excitement and then to
cap it all off the most important part
follows where every member gets their
own sentence as they appear one after
another from the smoke it really drives
home how important asked that is to the
squad and how much the black balls live
and die together I really like this kind
of comrade declaration seeds and Black
Clover has been some of the best at that
despite being in a scene that some
people might find a little bit cheesy it
maintains a proper Edge to make the
whole thing look so cool and Epic
[Music]
Heroes do what Heroes do in this next
scene from my hero Academia
all might no stranger to these moments
in fact the first season ended with him
putting a solo rescue however he's
brought his buddies around this time and
they waste no time laying waste to the
villains in this scene that started out
quite awkwardly comedic I mean pizza
delivery Honestly though I like the
rather wholesome Touch of awkwardness
shown in the villain's side before
things get serious with a big or might
smash the heroes waste no time attacking
as the tempo of the scene shoots up into
a frenzy now who had the best entrance
here I think Ed shot had a pretty good
one don't you think there's also a
rather touching moment at the end with
all might and bark will go the two had a
very rich history together and it's nice
to see moments like these that serve to
build it further if you think that's
cool we've got more waiting ahead but
for now go hit that like button if
you've been enjoying this video likes
comments views shares and the like all
tell me you've enjoyed watching these
videos so if you want to see more mental
characters coming in and being awesome
then just let me know through the
numbers thanks for your time and let's
get the ball rolling once again
now we all know about Luffy and the
punch that was heard all over the world
but what about the things that happened
next of note was rayleigh's entrance to
the seed which marks his debut as an
active part of the story he makes his
grand entrance but like the scene before
this it's not without some comedic
elements we have the power of hindsight
but I just found it funny that
everyone's worried about the giant
instead of you know freaking Rayleigh
himself the guy who demonstrated the
power of conqueror haki you also gotta
love how chill really was in the whole
ordeal this along with how he addresses
Luffy and everyone is overall a scene
that really sets a tone for his
relationship with the protagonist later
and for me that's what makes a great
debut at an entrance for the ages he'd
proved to be an invaluable mentor to
Newfie but that's a town for another
time for now let's sit back and relish
in this epic debut
foreign
Kenshin trust and betrayal opens with
one of these and it sets the tone for
Our Hero's origin story
[Music]
hiko sejuro is one overpowered monster
that certainly should be how Kenshin
still going by shinta at the time saw
him and he mercilessly slew the group of
Bandits with ease it's a simple scene
and all but at this point you can
already tell that this four-part OVA is
gonna be one that's a lot darker than
the majority of the mainline series one
The Tales of kenshin's trials and
tribulations before becoming the man he
was at the start of the series you gotta
love hiko's demeanor as he dispatches
the bandits and I personally give two
thumbs up to the shot of him against the
Moon it just gives the sort of calm yet
dangerous Ambiance that we've come to
always expect from the series strongest
character to further illustrate the
point look at how the poor guy who tried
to attack him was annihilated a good
debut involves quickly re-establishing
the character and getting the people to
know him Rayleigh does it and hiko does
it even better here if we're going with
giving the audience the sense of danger
lastly we finish with Demon Slayer
foreign
saving the gang in darky's realm I said
it was short and sweet but it's all
sorts of Epic with the way tengin wasted
no time dealing with the Obi in such a
graceful yet powerful way well guess who
did it again and in the arcs climactic
fight at that I mentioned this in the
previous video but now you can watch
lightning strike twice as Tenga makes
another epic interception and save just
when we all thought he's down for the
count he comes in the clutch and saves
dunjiro from gyotaro and he just has to
do it in the most epic way possible just
like most things Demon Slayer is the
presentation that lives this moment up
more than where it should be and we've
got to thank the anime team for that the
music the slow cut in and the responding
attack all lead us to a moment that's
once again short but sweet is one motion
but it's one motion that gives you so
much impact that you can't help but feel
Goosebumps watching this short clip if
this doesn't establish 10gint as one of
the most badass pillars the anime has
shown so far then I don't know what does
foreign
with that we wrap up today's list it's
short compared to the usual list but I
do hope that you all had fun watching
these scenes today if you've got any
further suggestions for volume 3 or a
completely different list you want to
see then leave a comment and I'll see
what I can do for you that's it for
today though I hope you enjoyed it and
thank you all for watching until next
time